when I was first appointed to this or
suggested that I take this job one of
the things you have to do is have a an
audience or a interview with the
President of the United States something
that doesn't come often and I knew just
about everybody knows George Bush's
abhorrence of cellphones I certainly
knew it so I go in on my day of the
interview and I'm there with the
president and his chief of staff in the
middle of the whole thing my cell phone
goes off a kid he nod and I said to
myself I'm dead that's it it's over
well it wasn't and it didn't luckily
hold me up I did find out was my wife
calling me which wasn't but whenever you
hear whenever whenever you give that
admonition about turning off the cell
phones that it brings that experience to
mind now I left about eight years ago to
take over this position went out and
prior to that I was the US attorney up
here in San Francisco and I'd have
occasion to come down here periodically
and talk to the law school when I left
eight years ago Stanford was one of the
most prestigious premier educational
institutions in the United States I come
back to find that it is nothing more
than a typical football Factory
given hey I got the [ __ ] huh
in any event what I'd like to do I'm
happy you call it a conversation what
I'd like to do tonight is talk a little
bit about where we've been in the last
six or seven years and where we are
today and where we're going in terms of
our priorities then talk a little bit
about lessons I've learned mistakes I've
made in terms of trying to bring the
bureau through this period and the end
talk a little bit about what mike said
in terms of the legal environment which
we find ourselves and the extraordinary
importance of the dialogue with regard
to the balancing of national security
against privacy civil liberties and the
like let me start off if I could with a
little bit of background the bureau Mike
has told you a little bit about it we
got about 32,000 people now of those
32,000 approximately 13,000 our agents
we are dispersed we have 56 field
offices around the country large offices
and we have 400 resident agencies which
are satellite offices so we pretty much
cover the United States we have overseas
now 61 legal attache offices grown
substantially over the last few years
and as Mike pointed out we have a budget
and now about 7.5 billion dollars so
it's a rather large organization and
we've grown rather substantially over
the last few years
basically in response to what happened
on September 11th and for us September
11th was a watershed
it was a watershed because it drove us
to change rather dramatically our focus
it required us to change the metrics and
it has done so as a result of what
happened on September 11 prior prior to
September 11th yes we had a number of
television shows we have a an exalted
history we actually had a 100th
anniversary last year but prior to
September 11th the American public
expected us to go out investigate crimes
after they occurred including terrorist
attacks
before September 11th you had the 1993
bombings of the twin towers in New York
he had the 1995 Oklahoma City bombing
McVeigh several people lost their lives
and that East African bombings the
Khobar towers bombing in Saudi Arabia
the bombing of the Cole off Yemen and
every one of these instances the
American public would look at us and the
FBI would go out as we have
traditionally done to do the
investigation identify those responsible
and bring them to justice that changed
on September 11 and a metric was no
longer the FBI going out and
investigating and bringing the persons
to justice it was why did the FBI let
this happen I tend to think in
reflecting back upon it that part of it
may well be that the nineteen hijackers
immediately responsible for what
happened on September 11th killed
themselves in the events of that day and
so the focus was not on who is
responsible so much because fairly
quickly afterwards we determined that
the 19 hijackers had killed themselves
were immediately responsible but why did
the CIA why did the FBI why did NSA why
did our intelligence and law enforcement
agencies let this let this happen and so
the metric came from a change from
who've you arrested who've you indicted
who have you convicted to how did you
let this happen and the one metric is
not let it happen again
front for us that was a dramatic
dramatic change and a catalyst for
change in the bureau and since then I
would say that we've gone through maybe
three phases of development as a result
of what happened on September 11th the
first one I would call triage
immediately the immediate response a
second I would say laying the foundation
of a domestic intelligence agency in the
third now talked about briefly is
maturation maturation of the
intelligence capacity of the bureau let
me start with triage in the immediate
aftermath of September 11th we had to do
a number of things first of all was
prioritize and priorities a
prioritization means actually
prioritizing that means determining your
priorities is setting them as a
priorities and making sure the personnel
the money the support goes to those
particular priorities and so the first
thing we did is prioritize
counterterrorism was number one
counterintelligence protecting our
secrets was number two and number three
on the national security side was cyber
on the criminal side we had been as as
Mike pointed out we have over 200
violations probably far more than that
that we're responsible for we had to
prioritize on the criminal side so was
first of all public corruption and
secondly civil rights and you may ask
why do you prioritize those two in the
answer the quick answer is because if we
do not do it nobody else does you cannot
count on another agency to investigate
the civil rights abuses or the public
corruption that you see in federal state
local governments a third area on the
criminal side was international
transnational organized crime because we
investigate across state borders across
national and international borders and
something that state local law law
enforcement cannot do the same time back
in 2001 2002 white-collar crime was big
if you recall we had Enron we de
HealthSouth we had WorldCom we had quest
any number of very large frauds
perpetrated by large corporations in
which investors lost millions and indeed
billions of dollars so the fourth on the
criminal side was white-collar crime and
the fifth was violent crime mainly
because anybody is familiar with the
devastation of violent crime on our
cities knows that whatever agency you're
in and you can contribute to reduction
of that violent crime you should so the
first thing for us to do was prioritize
putting counterterrorism number one we
shift a 2,000 agents from the criminal
programs over to counterterrorism 1,500
of those agents were doing drug cases
the other 500 were doing on smaller
white-collar criminal cases but we
needed those resources to investigate
what happened on September 11th and to
investigate and follow up on the series
of threats that we had after September
11th that seemed immediate and imminent
the other part was at that
building up what we call Joint Terrorism
Task Forces where we had 35 of them
before September 11th we now have 106
and they are we are led by the FBI but
contributors are our state local law
enforcement other federal agencies so
that we leverage our ability to address
terrorism in each one of our communities
not just with the FBI not just with
federal resources but also pulling in
the sheriffs and the sheriff's deputies
and police officers and the others who
are so essential to protecting us
against the next terrorist attack as I
say we build up our legal attache
offices overseas and places that we have
not been before places like Saudi Arabia
UAE Qatar places in the Middle East
where terrorism was hot and so we build
up the the investigative capabilities on
the counterterrorism side and one other
factor that came into play then that we
recognized we had to change and that it
was the presumption prior to September
11th that you did not disclose anything
about your investigations to anybody
else and had to reverse that presumption
so that whatever information we
discovered the United States relating to
terrorism could be integrated with that
intelligence developed by the CIA NSA
dia any of the intelligence communities
overseas so that we had the full picture
and not just part of the picture that is
what I'll call triage at first six
months of first year at the same time we
understood there was a there's a ongoing
debate in the United States as to
whether the FBI should be split take the
criminal programs leave it with the FBI
take counterintelligence
counterterrorism and intelligence and
have a domestic a separate domestic
intelligence agency it ought to be
probably one of the worst ideas for the
United States in being effective in
addressing terrorism but the fact the
matter is we had to augment our
capabilities we're building up and a
domestic intelligence capability we over
the years to the extent that we have a
history of capability it has been in
what I would call collection using the
elegance community jargon and that is we
have been particularly good in the four
areas basically four areas of collection
the first areas the sources witnesses
interviews what the intelligence
community calls human we've been
particularly good also in conducting
wires whether it be criminal wires under
what's called title three or national
security wires under the pursuant to an
order of the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court whenever we do a wire
we do it with the approval and by a wire
I mean an interception of substantive
conversations we do it with the approval
of a court whether it be an art a
regular article 3 court or the FISA
Court the third area which is
tremendously important collection is
surveillance not necessarily the
electronic surveillance but the physical
surveillance trailing people around
aerial surveillance and the fourth area
in which we've been particularly good in
the past is forensics DNA fingerprints
explosives and the like we're good at
that have been good at that for most of
our hundred years what we lacked was an
intelligence capability and so the next
part was putting in place the foundation
for an Intelligence Agency and that
meant hiring approximately a thousand
analysts building up back at
headquarters will be called the
intelligence directorate each of our 56
field offices field intelligence groups
and then putting in place the databases
the search engines that you need to put
the various pulled of various dots
together so that it paints a picture of
the threat that you're trying to try to
trying to intercept so to put that into
place for the next couple two or three
years and then we got to a place which I
call maturation it's something that I
had missed and the essence of actually a
domestic intelligence agency that I had
missed at the outset and that is to two
areas are called one is mindset and the
other is skillset in terms of mindset we
in the Bureau
have been reactive most of our history
and that is event happens we go in and
investigate afterwards and if you asked
any of us five six eight ten years ago
about the threat from organized crime or
the threat from Hezbollah on Hamas or al
Kate or what-have-you
we would turn to the number of cases we
had open on those particular threats to
define the threat and it was always
reactive it was what we knew but is so
much more important though if you're
going to anticipate a tax is
understanding what you do not know the
gaps it's one thing to know and be on
top of something it's another thing to
identify a gap of your knowledge
identify a threat identify a gap and
then collect to fill that gap and so for
us it was if you want to anticipate an
attack you have to look at it
differently than we had traditionally in
the law enforcement mode and that's
identifying the gaps in our knowledge
and any particular threat it can be
gangs could be ms-13 18th Street gang
Taliban gang over here in East Palo Alto
understanding who the leaders are
understanding the gaps in our knowledge
is as important as anything else if we
are to intercept and address that
particular threat so mindset was a piece
of it the other piece of it was building
up the expertise and by expertise I'd
always thought just an analyst as an
analyst an analyst but the fact that
matter there are degrees of expertise
when you develop a competent domestic
intelligence service that you have to
build to you have to have reports
officers that know how to disseminate
the information throughout the
intelligence community you need two main
managers to understand the domain domain
for our office here is Northern
California what are the threats here in
West our familia my Mexican Mafia
sureños noir danios white-collar crime
public corruption across the board
understanding the domain and the gaps in
your knowledge was part of that and the
domain manager handles that requirements
manager all these skill sets we had to
start building and that's part of the
process that I described now as match or
maturation and so if you look at us at
this point we have grown we have laid
the foundation of the domestic and
capability that we need but at the same
time we have allocated our resources do
and continue the investigations that we
have traditionally undertaken if you if
you look at as I indicated we had to
change our priorities back early in 2000
2002 right after September 11th if you
look at those priorities today and
through the the prism of what is
happening throughout the United States
today you'll see that those priorities
we established back then or pretty much
are and should be the priorities of
today with the capabilities we have now
we're addressing mortgage fraud terms of
white-collar crime we have 2,700
approximately 2,700 cases around the
country we have 20 proximately 2,500 of
healthcare fraud cases around the
country in addition to mortgage fraud we
have any number of corporate fraud case
and security fraud cases that we're
addressing given the economic turn town
of the last a couple of years
counterterrorism you can understand is
still our number one priority
particularly if you've read the
newspapers in last month six weeks to
two months the first case we had was out
of Charlotte individual by the name of
Boyd I arrested approximately two months
ago with a number of other people in the
last two to three weeks we've had a case
out of Dallas Texas an individual have
sought to blow up a bank building
another individual in Springfield
Illinois who sought to build up blow up
a federal building and then we had the
case in Denver in New York an individual
who was out according to the papers
looking for the ingredients to to put
together a explosive device using a TATP
and so there been a series of cases in
the last six weeks or two months that
would indicate that we can't take our
eye off the ball when it comes to when
it comes to terrorism a brief aside on
on on terrorism the cases we have here
persons were radicalized in a variety of
ways but if you look at what we face
overseas at this point er domestically
you can see
we still face a substantial al-qaeda
presence in the western part of Pakistan
eastern Afghanistan I was called
Waziristan the federally administered
tribal areas with a intent to develop
Westerners who can insert themselves
into Western societies and undertake
attacks you have al Qaeda that is
expanded in the last couple of years to
places like Somalia Yemen North Africa
al-qaida in the Maghreb it's called
which is still a substantial threat for
us to address you have those here travel
over to be trained and then you have
others here in the United States been
radicalized here whether P by associates
or mentors or indeed the internet
counterterrorism white-collar crime and
lastly I'll spend a moment on violent
crime our statistics we push out every
six months have shown over the last
several years the violent violent crime
is down the fact that matter is if you
look at where we are today and what we
can anticipate in the future you will
see that we locked up a number of people
in the 90s and many of them are going to
get out and that's even without the
possible 40,000 that are going to be
released in California given the the
budget crisis and these unfortunately
often are individuals who have no skills
other than the skills they picked up in
prison and they're not the skills that
are marketable in the in the outside and
acquaintances they met in the inside
that will be acquaintances on the
outside and they're coming out to an
economy where even if you have a skill
set it is very difficult to find a job
so I have very few illusions that the
violent crime that we've seen is going
to continue on its downward pace
unfortunately I think we'll probably
probably begin to rise and in that in
addressing that we go back to what is
absolutely essential to our capability
whether it be counterterrorism or just
about any threat and that is task forces
and working together with state and
state local law enforcement so if you
look at where we've been
September 11th was a transforming event
for us we build up in the triage we've
moved persons from the criminal side of
the house to the national security side
of the house but with the threats we see
today particularly the domestic threats
in white collar arena in the gang arena
I will be building up our resources over
on the on the criminal side the last
note on that public corruption I said
was our number one priority then number
one priority now because if we don't do
it nobody else will occasionally they
get the headlines
Jefferson congressman Jefferson being
one Blagojevich out of the Illinois
being another and a number of you may
have read about the arrest of 40
separate individuals in New Jersey
several months ago and so that's
something you cannot take your eye off
of and right now we have a conjunction
of events in which the federal
government is pushing out a great amount
of money in the tarp program the
stimulant program in the like through
federal state and local entities which
given the amounts that they have are to
a certain extent invitation to fraud and
corruption and so in addition to what we
are doing with the mortgage fraud crisis
what we're doing in the securities fraud
corporate fraud
arena we have the prospect of a lot of
work down the road with the money's
flowing from the federal government
through these various and state local
entities if you ask for the future in
terms of our programs if you ask for
what do we look what's a bureau look
like five ten twenty years down the road
which we try to do there are a
combination of factors that contribute
it to the belief that we will continue
to grow as a national but more
particularly in international law
enforcement / national security /
Intelligence Agency if you read the
books by Tom Friedman or read his
columns in the impact of globalization
he talks about globalization when it
comes to merchandise or manufacturing or
financing in the like what he has not
yet addressed is globalization when it
comes to
I'm globalization when it comes to
terrorism and the ability of terrorists
and criminals to jump across borders
with ease to commit crimes whether it be
terrorism or white-collar narcotics
trafficking trafficking persons and in
the future because of globalization and
we're not so insulated as we have been
in the past the oceans no longer protect
us it will be I you part our mission to
be the bridge between state local law
enforcement and our counterparts
overseas which again gets back to why we
have built up so many legal attache
offices
let me turn for a moment to talk briefly
about lessons learned in terms of the
management aspect of of being with the
Bureau as we've gone through this this
evolution and therefore four areas I'll
touch on the one thing that I've learned
early on but it's always reinforced day
in and day out is the most important
thing you have is your people and people
in at least two ways most important
decisions I make are not on a particular
subject matter particular investigation
or actually when I was a prosecutor a
particular prosecution most important
decisions I would make an 8-point time
or the people who I promote who I put
into particular positions in terms of
transforming and organization the most
important component generally unless
you're high-tech and very high-tech is
the people and the time you spend one
spends too little time on that one
always should spend more time but it's
absolutely essential the other aspect of
focusing on the people and the persons
in this at this time is the necessity to
in some sense change a culture a culture
and the Bureau of investigating after
the fact and being applauded and patted
on the back end described and defined in
television commentary
as being glorified to a an FBI that is
focused on particular threats where you
don't end up in the courtroom the next
day you don't end up slapping cuffs on
somebody and have the satisfaction of
seeing them go to trial be convicted and
go to jail and so agents have joined the
bureau with that in mind I want to put
people behind bars I as a prosecutor I
love to put I love what I did
I love trying the case and I was
satisfied if I got a conviction but
changing that culture so that you
understand the importance
what's primarily important to the
American public no not another terrorist
attack preserving our secrets from those
who would steal them is a change that is
very difficult in the best of times and
difficult also in the worst of times
although I will say that after September
11th one of the side effects of
September 11th was the understanding by
just about everybody in the bureau that
we could not let it happen again
and so if we had not had that catalyzing
event I do not believe we would have
made the strides that we've made today
to change the culture to understand the
priorities and to bring everybody in the
bureau whether you're an agent or an
analysts or a professional staff person
behind the concept that the American
public expects us to stop in September
11th and we have to do it even though
more often than not it will not result
in cuffs being slapped on somebody and
somebody going to jail but people on
handling the people and talking about
the culture and bringing the the the
wonderful people that work in the Bureau
along to understand that vision has been
a challenge but it's been eased by the
fact that everybody after September 11th
realized that we had to change the
second area which is tremendously
problematic that I had never fully
understood never expected to be
problematic and that is information
technology and the integration of
information technology in and
organization
and when I come to find after I probably
was about 197 million dollar mistake is
that you have to keep your fingers on it
now talk about that in a moment but the
challenge in this technological world is
taking an individual who is
knowledgeable in technology on the one
hand and putting them together and
marrying that individual with a person
who knows and understands the business
practices if all you're going to do is
digitize a standard business practice
that's not too bad and that marriage is
fairly easy if on the other hand you
want to update and modernize your
business practices and use technology to
do it it is tremendously difficult on
the one hand I have the geeks as I call
them and they are affectionately known
within the building who know the
technology on the other hand you have
agents who have been and know the
business they've been in the business
for 10 15 20 25 years and know the
business practices but the marriage is
very very difficult and one of the first
big mistakes I made was continuing on a
software package thinking would work and
only to come to find that there was not
met you did not have that marriage of
the information technologists and the
person to understand to knew and
understood and knew the business
practices of the bureau and is a is a
huge challenge for anybody in this
business who has to upgrade the
technology while still running the
business at a at a clip third area is
what I would call a combination of
delegation and execution those of you
are business students there are tons of
books out there about execution and
execution is important and every one of
those books read them they're good
because execution people can come up
with ideas but executing the ideas is a
hard part and it comes to intersect
somewhat with delegation one of the
things I recall and I'm a strong
supporter as you might imagine the
Marine Corps and the training got in the
Marine Corps I wouldn't be here without
that training but one of the things that
are
is going through Officer Candidate
School in the Marine Corps
and you get in there and you're and it
was ten weeks or whatever it was you get
about three a week third or four and
they start evaluating you about you
evaluate you obviously on your fitness
forward can you do it they evaluate you
on how you're doing on the scholastic
part of it and on the exams and the like
and I did pretty well on both of those
and then they got down to another area
called delegation I said what are you
talking about delegation lately and I
didn't do well on that and I said well
why are you downgrading me on delegation
I said because one of the most important
things you will learn as a Marine Corps
officer in your in your duty in your
assignments is the ability to delegate
and I say they're intertwined delegation
and execution because indeed they are
you have to know how to delegate you
have to know to whom to delegate and you
have to know what to delegate if you're
gay get something executed and I've made
any number of mistakes in that regard I
I when I first came in this job I read
most of the books that I could help me
be a manager prior to that I've been a
lawyer and there is nothing more
antithetical than being a manager than
being a lawyer and I so I got the
management books and the management
books always talked about the CEO where
the head of an organization should be up
in the balcony and not on the dance
floor you read that you've seen that
responsible for strategy and direction
and all the rest of those good things
well I started to did that do that for a
period of time one one area I knew I
could not delegate and that was a
terrorism you had to brief the president
every day for four years and in briefing
the president every day for four years
and then once a week afterwards you
learn you cannot delegate that you push
it through the organization and you have
to be ready to respond that was pretty
easy but the mistake I made in
technology was to rely on advisers and
not ask the hard questions be up in that
balcony and say okay and listen to the
platitudes about how good it's going to
be without asking the hard questions and
inevitably in my own - I knew I should
have been asking and so when it comes to
being on the knee in the balcony or on
the dance floor yes you have to learn
when to delegate and leave it
the dancefloor but there are other areas
that you have to do you cannot delegate
they're so important that you intimately
have to know the ins and outs of them
that's the third the fourth is listening
and the importance of listening and
finding ways to listen in a position
such as mine everybody below you wants
to tell you how good things are and
finding out how bad things are as the
real is the real challenge and it's
listening one quick anecdote about
listening some time ago when I was I
moved from California went to the US
Attorney's Office in Boston and was
pretty much my first supervisory
position I was head of the Criminal
Division the US Attorney's Office in
Boston in over a period of time you'll
find if you manage people that there are
two types of people that come into your
office those that want to face time they
can't want to come in and talk to you
and the other people want to come in and
get a decision or to get something done
and after a period of time if you're
busy and dear going day in and day out
you start asking the question as soon as
a person appears in the doorway you see
what's the issue is it something I have
to decide or you want to talk so over a
period of time I got in the habit of
asking what's the issue well one night I
come home and I come into the kitchen
and my wife I greet me at the door and
we have a conversation as you would had
a night a dialogue to which she starts
talking to me about what happened the
kids at school and I'm a little bit
tired and I've been asking the question
all day so I say darling what's the
issue
my wife it was gentle hi all of a sudden
turns into a tigress I am your wife I am
NOT somebody serves under you don't you
ever ask me what the issue is you sit
there and you listen to me too I'm true
it's absolute truth and I would like to
say I've learned the lesson I'm not
certain she would agree however but
apart from a commentary on intra marital
success I would tell you that if it's a
lesson to learn as somebody who is in a
business of running other things you
want to solve the problems and you don't
spend enough time listening and if I
have one great failure it is I'll sit
down in the meeting I'll hear about five
minutes of it and then I want to jump to
a solution
and the fact that matter is I should do
more listening and so that's a fourth
area that I tried to learn in the last
in the last several out of several years
let me turn for a moment and finish up
on the legal side of the house because
this might points out and as we knew in
September eleventh we'd have to build up
a domestic intelligence capability and
we'd have to address our mission in a
far different way when you're within the
court system when you're doing criminal
cases the monitor is the court system
itself you don't get a search warrant
without going to a magistrate and laying
out the probable cause you have a
defense counsel it's always questioning
what happened and so there is an
automatic monitor when you are
developing intelligence on the other
hand there is no court system monitor to
the extent that you have it in the
criminal justice system and there is a
balance that has to be made day in and
day out between national security and
civil liberties I am comfortable with
that balance how as to how we have
addressed it over the
number of years it is part of our
history it is part of our legacy okay in
a moment Rita an excerpt from what we
admonish our our special agents but if
you look back at the what has happened
in terms of that balance over the last
several years you've had the Patriot Act
for that people are some people are
supportive of some question the fact the
matter is the Patriot Act dropped the
walls between the intelligence community
on the one hand and the law-enforcement
community on the other before the
Patriot Act one half of the FBI could
not talk to the other half of the FBI
because one half the FBI was in the
criminal arena the other half was in the
intelligence arena the information that
had gathered by the CIA or NSA overseas
could not be shared with the FBI nor
could the FBI share with those entities
the information had been developed here
and so inevitably in each of those
agencies you had only a partial picture
of what was happening and so the Patriot
Act try and it's up for the revisions
that they're talking about
day in and day out now and but I am very
comfortable and supportive and believe
that that is absolutely essential to
assuring the safety of the country
without unduly burdening civil liberties
or privacy same thing with the debate on
the FISA Court Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act what is required in
order for us to by us I mean ourselves
the intelligence community to get a
order from the FISA Court to intercept
conversations it absolutely had to be
updated probably will have to be updated
every other year because of the
developing technology peer to peer Skype
encryption all of these things that made
it increasingly difficult for us to do
our job if we are to prevent another
terrorist attack and so if you look at
the legislation that has been passed if
you look at what we have done in the
Bureau since September 11th
uncomfortable that we have done what we
should within the confines of the
Constitution the statutes and the
attorney general guidelines let me
finish with reading you the admonition
that we give new agents or at least an
excerpt of the admonition that we give
new agents
as they come out and get their their
badges for the past 100 years the FBI is
do it for some of the best of America we
have disrupted terrorist cells we have
rescued hostages from kidnappers we have
broken the backs of organized criminal
groups we have put violent criminals and
drug dealers behind bars and we have
done this by adhering to our motto of
fidelity bravery and integrity and by
respecting the authority given to us
under the Constitution today we are
building on that legacy as we focus on
our top priority preventing another
terrorist attack in the United States
and it is indeed a time of change in the
bureau about our values never change as
always we will protect the security of
our nation while upholding the civil
rights guaranteed by the Constitution to
every citizen it is not enough to
prevent foreign countries from stealing
our secrets we must prevent that
happening while still upholding the rule
of law it is not enough to stop the
terrorists we must stop him while
maintaining civil liberties it is not
enough to catch the criminal we must
catch him while respecting his civil
rights the rule of law civil liberties
civil rights these are not our burdens
they are what makes us better and they
are would have made us better for the
past 100 years you each of you new
agents are charged with upholding this
legacy thank you and I'd be happy to
answer any questions you have
got it
you know what this is like I'll tell you
what there's like I go out and visit my
office's today I was up in Seattle
visiting my office and at the end I
always say you got any questions or
things I ought to know and there is dead
silence the only difference being that
there's dead silence when I ask my
people that because they expect if they
ask question I don't like they'll be
transferred to Yemen or someplace but I
can't transfer I don't control you so
and so let me go right over here yes sir
right hook I'm sorry I was looking for
the person with microphone thank you my
name is Joe syndrome and what I wanted
to ask you is with regards to Vladimir
Putin is he understand he may be
building a factory in Venezuela for a to
build ak-47 something we don't know
about that's a the question was a mere
Putin building a factory in Venezuela we
stay away from that that's a little bit
too precise for an answer
you know you know what you learn in this
business is the duck questions and
something like that even if I did know
the answer I'm not certain in this in
this arena
I could I could discuss it yes sir over
here the yellow okay and I think hello a
question is in my opinion why would have
we not had another terrorist incident I
attribute it to a number of factors the
first factor is the the going into
Afghanistan in an immediate wake of
September 11th in removing the sanctuary
for al Qaeda and that was instrumental
prior to that training recruiting
training the September 11th plot was
hatched and organized and run from the
sanctuary of Afghanistan and removing
that sanctuary was the first order of
business and appropriately so secondly
the work that principally the CIA is
done overseas and taking off the
leadership of al Qaeda if you look at
somebody like Khalid Sheikh Mohammed who
is responsible for September 11th he was
spent a couple of years and in North
Carolina at college he understood the
United States a computer literate
charismatic a tremendous organizer a
confidant of bin Laden you take somebody
like that off the playing field and
there it is very very difficult to
replace them and over a series of years
the CIA has taken off the major
leadership of al Qaeda and regardless of
how you feel about the various aspects
of it it has had a effect on our ability
to to prevent another terrorist attack
in the third area I would say is
somewhat what I've described is the
vigilance with in this country the Joint
Terrorism Task Forces the ability to
work with the rest of the intelligence
community to pick up a snippet of
information that would indicate that a a
terrorist plot is afoot and to disrupt
it before it comes to fruition right
here in the middle lady in blue
the question was we have the 56 field
offices and they're run by a special
agent in charge and you allude to the
autonomy they have they probably think
they have more autonomy than I can tell
you they wish they had more autonomy
than they have but how do we transform
part of it is developing leadership over
a period of time and leadership that
understands the mission and is going to
subscribe to that mission it takes a
while to replace and build it up the
other thing we do which is a we learned
from that New York Police Department
Bill Bratton who used to just took over
or no took over several years ago Los
Angeles Police Department establishment
established it in New York which is
called ComStat which means pulling in
statistics relating to crime by precinct
in every week having a meeting with the
precinct commanders where you you
confront them with the statistics and
confront them with asking them what are
they doing to drive down those
statistics we've adopted that we call it
SPS sessions don't I don't know what
stands for but if everybody every other
week I have four offices on the video
conference and I spend a two hours half
hour each going through what the threat
is in each of those offices and what
they're doing to address the threat to
fill the gaps where your sources where
are you lacking source coverage how many
title threes do you have what do you
need in terms of electronic surveillance
what else do you need in support and
what are you doing about it
how are you prioritizing and so it is a
give-and-take it gives me an opportunity
to learn more about the office it puts
them through a rigorous exercise and
preparing for that but draw also drives
the organization it's one of the
initiatives I think has been
particularly helpful during this period
of Metro Metro Metro zation let me go
right here sir
i InfraGard is a program we've got I
think 70,000 or something in InfraGard
now is a program we have outreach to
private industry where we have a network
with private industry focused
principally but not totally on the cyber
arena and it is exceptionally helpful
for us to learn what is happening in
various companies when it comes to the
cyber cyber arena particularly cyber
warfare and cyber intrusions and the
like and also as a mechanism that we
utilize to to pass on information to
those who remember the cyber the
InfraGard program so I give it high
marks and it's a program that we're
continuing to expand well one of the
issues I did not focus on and this
dialogue is the impact of cyber crime on
what we do across the board and if you
look at the future of the bureau one of
the the expanding areas for us is going
to be addressing cyber cyber attacks
denial service attacks worms viruses any
number of phishing schemes we just
yesterday took down a a group of
Egyptians and individuals in the United
States made over I think 70 arrests at
this point where we had a phishing
scheme that was operated in Egypt and
the United States with a number of
victims here but also a number of
victims overseas and that is going to be
an expanding area of interest for us yes
sir in the in the blue shirt there the
turquoise shirt and the wise words of
you know spider-man with power comes
responsibility
how does FBI what are some of the checks
and balances both internal so if we are
to prevent the abuse of power within it
and related to that you know what
happens when there is corruption and say
with an FBI yeah the question is we have
a lot of power I and our
responsibilities to affect persons lives
and there's not a one of us does not
understand that what do we do to prevent
that abuse when they mentioned - first
of all the Attorney General guidelines
we operate within the turn attorney
general guidelines applicable statutes
in the Constitution and basically
basically that means we get an
allegation we can do minimal
investigation to determine whether we
should do further investigation and so
there are levels of predication that we
have to meet before we we Institute or
utilize additional investigative tools
the most intrusive investigative tools
listening to conversations you know like
we can only do with a the approval of a
court showing appropriate probable cause
that's one aspect of it the other aspect
is a debate I've had with myself since
to a certain extent since I started to
be an agent the FBI you have to be 23
years of old you have to have three
years of work experience and you know
sparkling background all the rest of
that but what we the average age of our
graduating class of new agents is 30 and
almost all have had another career and
when I came in one of the things that
was problematic and still to a certain
extent as problematic is we would we do
very little recruiting on campuses
because we want the three years
experience and you have to be 23 and so
we're missing a lot of people yeah but
on the other hand the argument is made
and this is the one that I at this I am
persuaded about now is going to your
point we have a tremendous amount of
power we give an agent a badge and gun
and the ability to adversely impact a
person's life the most important thing
for our people then our judgement
maturity and understanding of the power
that we entrust to them so I have gone
back and forth and we're doing much more
recruiting on college campuses that
we've done before but I still think
given what you
point out the power that we have that
maturity and judgment are absolutely
essential in exercising that power yes
sir right oh yeah actually let me take
somebody in back I'm the blue sweater
yep right under the camera you can turn
around you'll be on camera you know the
guy in front of you and that's only
because he had a jacket on not to worry
you very nice describe how you went from
a reactive force to a proactive force
and you also said you have these 32,000
people so going from reactive to
proactive you have probably to increase
your speed a lot and especially your
speed of internal learning can you maybe
give us an insight with these two groups
you said you have the geeks and you have
the agents what mechanisms you have
internally to learn quickly and be ahead
of things then just afterwards looking
there what happened well let me let me
say we have a number of agents or geeks
also because we have when I was talking
about is those people or instituting
putting together the networks the
hardware the software in order for you
to exchange the information we have a
career path now we bring in people who
have the experience in the cyber arena
and teach them how to be agents and do
the investigative work and so we have a
series of career paths where we build
our building in our bringing in not only
the maturity and the judgment but a
particular degree of expertise that we
need I'll tell you with weapons of mass
destruction now we want we want chemists
we want biologists we had the site and
not the cyber but the anthrax attacks of
2002 and consequently we bring in
persons with that baseline expertise
which is in part contributes to the fact
that the average age of our graduating
class is 30 and within those particular
components we have I would say a fairly
good educational and training capability
so that we stay ahead whether it be
cyber or counterterrorism
counterintelligence we stay ahead of
are our adversaries one of the areas
that we have not done as good a job on
as I would like and that is developing
leadership and leaders when you talk
about judgment maturity you also want
leadership you want them you need
differently persons that come in they
need differing experiences different
periods in their career military does a
very good job we do an okay job but but
we're putting substantial emphasis on
building and maturing leadership
throughout the bureau for the next six
months the next year and that in my mind
is as important as anything else we do
where we go how about gentlemen and the
blue right and know with you both got
glasses yes sir you yellow it like that
separation that used to be noted
particularly was that buyer FBI was
domestic CIA was overseas if with the
expansion of FBI presence overseas that
line must be pretty blurred at times and
then as a follow-up
what about gaze on with foreign
intelligence organizations well it's
actually one the same question the you
will find that you I don't know whether
you're in the agency but you probably
spent time overseas and has seen the
back and forth between the bureau and
the and the agency prior to September
11th now we are embedded with the agency
the agency is embedded with us number
two person in my National Security
Division is an agency person and what
you find overseas is you have lawn for
just about every country has
intelligence components and law
enforcement components law enforcement
components are always leery of the
intelligence components intelligence
components are somewhat leery of the law
enforcement and so we are very good
partners now overseas and understanding
that information has to be shared
between us and we have to develop
information from the law enforcement
components as well as the as the
intelligence components if you look at
the UK you have mi5 mi6 mi5 at domestic
intelligence mi6 of the
CIA and then you have the met Scotland
Yard for instance and we maintain
relationships with all three of them as
does the CIA and we share between us
understanding that we cannot let
information drop between the cracks one
more question right
ah yes sir
that gets into I'm gonna give somebody
another question because I can't get
into we always let me just say whenever
we do a debriefing or a backward look we
learn something so you can assume that
we learn something one more and the lady
in back perhaps let me by people ask
what contributed to the collapse of the
economy two or three years ago some
people want to say it was fraud when you
see all the mortgage fraud cases we have
but I think most independent observers
would say it's a number of factors
bailing out of the housing market a
number of factors contributed to it but
with that sliver of a person's and who
have committed fraud and contributed to
that we have ongoing investigations and
we're locking them up day in and day out
and that will continue to be our role
those who committed fraud they will get
the cuffs slapped on them they will go
to jail and they will serve time and
with that thank you very much perfect
good pleasure